hello welcome to digital view the show
that uses all the tools the web can give
us to re-engineer the news agenda coming
up today voting online in the general
election could it happen here and what
would it do to voter turnout three years
of everyday sexism campaign but we ask
has anything really changed and can't
cook don't cook meet the kitchen hands
that will make culinary disasters a
thing of the past as ever we want to
know what do you think on Twitter this
week we want to know whether you would
feel comfortable voting online in
general election if you were told the
correct safeguards were in place let's
assume that so tweet yes or no using the
hashtag digital view and we'll round up
your views at the end of the program so
let's get right into that this year
millions of us will make the journey to
a polling station fill in a slip in
private and put it in the all-important
ballot box but what are the alternatives
while voting it electronic terminals
could give us results in just minutes
saving the election night nerves casting
a vote online would provide an enormous
boost to voter turnout and a hand sad
study found that even in this closely
fought election only forty-nine percent
of us say that they're certain to vote
but forty-five percent said they would
support some form of online voting well
let's talk this through with Lord
malloch-brown chairman of the electronic
voting company Smartmatic and of course
a former government minister a good see
lord browne so let's do the disclosure
thing right away Smartmatic is in the
vote in these in the business of trying
to get more people to use electronics
but talk us through the process that
you've used hitherto well look if this
was the election a few weeks ago in
Estonia a third of people did vote
online from their home computers or from
their mobile phones but the more not and
we provided that but the more normal
system we provide is one where you get a
biometric registration card ideally and
then you go to a polling station still
like in the past
there's a touchscreen computer on which
you vote and then as you said that vote
is calculated lectronimo counted at the
polling station and countered again
nationally but all done by computer and
we've counted nearly two and a half
billion votes around the world this way
and really have had it's been error-free
and it's been utterly secure there's
been no cyber into rivers security
problems I mean it just delivers much
quicker secure results and in an
election like Britain's with lots of
seats which are going to be very close
run things that's got to be a powerful
argument is it about the speed of the
results or is it more about getting more
people to actually vote oh it's very
much also as you say about that second
thing because the kind of modern polling
station needn't be the church hall or
the school close to where you live if
you've got a biometric ID you could vote
anywhere so you pop down to the lobby
and your office building you could pop
out across the road to a shopping ball
it would hugely convenience voting and
for one particular group younger voters
we're at the moment have much lower
registrations because they're at
university or in transient employment
somewhere for that group it would likely
drive up voting by twenty percent or
more to something more like the national
average for voters as a whole but this
is using a bespoke bit of kit isn't it
why not actually democratize it further
and put this ability to vote on my phone
on my tablet on my computer well I think
it's a skep to getting there and as I
say in Estonia we've already arrived at
that latter stage but there are
additional security problems about that
making sure it really is you who are
voting on your phone it's a lot more
secure than the postal ballot which is
now heavily used but it's not yet as
secure except in exceptional countries
like Estonia for normal voting Estonia
how does everything online you get your
passport your driving licence you're
sure life is lived online so it's
different but familiarity okay many
people are living there
lives online they're content to do
banking online they're content to buy
things online they content to go dating
online what why can't we take this step
into into voting online it's very
strange it's very strange the resistance
and I think it's around the fact that
it's a government-controlled activity
and we seem much less certain to let do
things with government online than with
our banks or in our personal
relationships but you know it's only a
matter of time clearly this is a
technology that's coming I mean when I
look at all the countries which had much
bigger voting problems places like the
Philippines or Brazil because they're
just much bigger countries with a lot
more votes to cast in a much wider
spread geography there they've felt the
imperative to make the jump and use
these systems very successfully in a
sense we've been a rather complacent
democracy and not felt the need for it
but i think this election with its close
results and uneven turnout is going to
be a wake-up call this is a slightly
ridiculous suggestion of the sort of TV
event but i make the comparison look in
2010 i think the stats are we've got
about sixty two million people only 49
million are a voting age 45 million of
those registers so that's not bad we
could do better but only 30 million
voted 10 million people voted for the X
Factor finalist two years ago could we
not turn television to turn the electing
a government into a television special
well perhaps but you know the x-factor
problem is that a lot you can vote
multiple times a lot of people I suspect
did and so you know they've got to be
security protocols in place but that's
where we'll get to we'll get to a point
in the lifetimes of many people watching
this program where they will cast their
votes in elections online and by the way
they may not just do it once every five
years we have an e voting technology
which we assume politicians will start
to use to test opinion between elections
a little bit like the way you can go
online to the Downing Street website and
sign up there if you believe in
something and you want to see it debated
in parliament well that much more
interactive modern democracy between
citizens and
and an MP's is I think also going to be
part of the future give me a prediction
we voting this year let's pass over the
fact we may do a second election in the
autumn let's say we go five years do you
think we'll have this ready for them I
well we certainly could it's absolutely
up to the politicians the Labor Party of
endorses technology they said they'd
bring it in I think the Tories are not
quite as far down the road as this the
other party's very much are and the
Speaker John Bercow published a digital
commission which also went in the same
direction so i think i think the
establishment is coming round to this
it's a win-win really it's going to if
you like revived democracy get turn out
our get people more excited but above
all get people more participating more
nor bar at Brown thank you very much to
do a good touch it thank you